Hey,
what's going on?
It's bill burr and it's the Monday morning podcasts from Monday,
July 29th,
2013.
How you doing?
Um,
I'm on the road right now.
I'm currently in New Orleans and I brought all my podcast stuff with me,
but of course I was kidding who I went to summer school,
I should have gone three out of the four years I went to high school.
I should actually go on all four years.
But a one year my math teacher gave me the d minus and then my senior year was
kind of like,
well what's the fucking point?
But um,
for the record I should have gone four times,
um,
all four years and feed those of you listening overseas,
basically summer school if you don't have it over there is basically you fucked
up so bad.
They gave you 10 months to get your shit together and evidently that wasn't
enough for you.
So no swimming,
no biking,
no experimental drugs for you and you have to go to fucking summer school.
So,
um,
next week I will have a power cord.
Here I am in New Orleans right now and I'm starting my acting gig.
I'm going to be here for the next couple,
two,
three weeks.
So,
uh,
yeah,
I hope these levels are all right.
I don't know how to fucking adjust them on this garage band thing.
That's what I'm recording it.
Um,
yeah.
You know,
it's,
it's the usual bullshit.
I just,
I just don't get along with technology.
Um,
I like to think I didn't start it.
Maybe I did.
Maybe I did start it by just,
you know,
you know what my problem was?
I thought it was just a fad,
you know,
I thought computers in this new technology and shit.
I just thought it was some,
I just,
I looked at it as an extension to video games.
I looked at it and it was just a time sponge.
I don't want to do that shit.
I want to go out and go fucking do something,
you know?
And uh,
you know,
I think we can say at this point that I was wrong.
I remember when I was living with Bobby Kelly,
it weighs 47 times kid.
Um,
back in 1995 or 96 or whatever the fuck we lived together and he was,
he,
he just jumped all over that ship.
And what was funny is I was smarter than Bobby Kelly in 1995 and
18 years later,
he is way smarter than I am because my just,
I just,
there was just something right out right out,
right out of the gate that I just did not like about computers.
I just didn't like it.
You know,
I remember back in high school when they had like the fucking piece of paper was
coming out of the things and you know,
you had,
you know,
what,
what the fuck computer programming,
I was just sitting there like,
I would rather dig for fossils than fucking sit here another minute,
typing in,
run,
enter whatever the fuck we were doing.
And it was,
it was not fun on any fucking level.
So anyways,
I'm not going to lie to you.
I mean,
I wasn't ever really that smart,
but I wasn't a fucking moron.
But my lack of embracing computers,
I feel like in an odd way,
I've gone from being literate to completely fucking illiterate.
Uh,
I get unbelievably frustrated with them.
And,
uh,
you know what I do?
You know what I do with my computer a lot?
I grab it,
I pick the fucking thing up and I,
and I hold it over my head like fucking Hulk Hogan when he's going to slam a
chair,
get somebody fucking sweaty back,
bite my bottom lip.
Now I never do it because it costs so much fucking money,
but I swear to God,
okay,
one of these times I just want to do it once,
just one time,
but I know instantly I'll regret it.
But,
um,
I just,
I apologize for the poor quality of this podcast.
So I'm going to try to speak in regular speaking tones.
I won't do my usual fucking with the microphone,
which is my crutch to make this podcast remotely entertaining.
And also I'm in a,
I'm in a hotel room.
If those of you who is listened to my podcast for a long time,
remember when I was stuck in New Jersey during that fucking hurricane or
whatever the hell was going on,
I was a little too loud and security came.
I don't feel like doing that.
All right?
It's one thing if I'm out on the road and I'm just doing a comedy Gig,
who gives a fuck,
right?
I'm on,
I'm a made guy and strip mall comedy clubs so I can piss off the front desk.
But as far as this act and shit goes,
I'm a Newbie.
So I don't feel like,
uh,
I don't feel like a,
you know,
screwing things up right out of the gate.
So I'm going to try to behave myself as much as humanly possible.
Um,
but I was also thinking,
you know,
I,
I want to get better computers and I also want to visit.
Is it,
does that sound dumb?
Am I even saying that wrong?
I want to all be good computers.
I will do to come to bear,
um,
complete shit head.
You know,
something.
What does it say about you that you're actually fucking listening to this?
You know,
I don't know why you're listening to why at this point you really should hit
stop and fucking delete it or whatever.
But you know,
I'm not here to tell you what the dope.
So anyways,
uh,
I'd like to become more proficient when it comes to the computer sciences.
Is that a home source to say it gives a fuck?
Um,
and also I would,
I would like to quit dicking around on the computer.
I find that the other day you need like 40,
50 hours.
That's all you need.
40,
50 hours and you'll know how to fly a plane.
I mean,
you've got the classroom shit too,
but as far as just like learning how to fly the fucking thing.
Somebody told me the other day,
I don't know,
I was talking about the motorcycle license thing.
I would gloating.
Then I finally fucking got one.
And uh,
you know,
it's no,
it's fucking hilarious.
I'm actually afraid to go out and just go ride a bike down the street,
but whatever.
I got one,
I got him,
I got,
I got the fucking thing.
So this person was telling me that they,
uh,
that they had a pilot's license.
Now it's fucking cool thing to do.
And I was like,
well,
how many hours?
And he said,
well,
buy 10 hours in,
you can pretty much fly the fucking thing.
He goes,
obviously,
you know,
you could hurt [inaudible] screw up,
but you're proficient enough where you could get yourself up off the ground
before you flew into the side of somebody's silo.
But,
uh,
but I was just,
that just has been sticking with me all week.
That if I spent 10 hours doing that,
I would actually,
you know,
if,
God forbid I was ever on some fucking doing some hell Gig,
or I'm flying one of those fucking planes with,
you know,
in one of those planes would like the water skis and the guy has a fucking
aneurysm and I got 10 hours under my belt,
I could fucking crawl up there.
You know,
it'd be funny about that is you'd actually have to sit on the guy's lap.
If it was a really cramped little as plain with like the one seat and shit,
you'd have to do that.
You'd have to push through whatever your level of homophobia is,
you know,
depending,
depending if he had it on automatic pilot,
which I don't even know if they have that option on one of those little fucking
plates.
What's the deal with bleeds?
I mean they just like cars where you can buy the Ford escort of planes.
Why the fuck would you do that?
And you want the,
you want the rest proofing five.
Let's all just take it as,
I'll buy right off the lot.
Thank you.
Um,
vinyl interior.
Anyways,
so I was just a how much time I spend just wasting,
you know,
watching people getting kicked in the balls,
all the porn I have to sift through to find something that even remotely turns
me on at this point because I've watched so much of that fucking shit.
You know,
the last point,
oh,
I watched,
I actually apologize to the three women that were in it when I was done
sort of got,
you know,
I was just like,
God,
Jesus Christ,
what am I.
Dot.
I'm sorry ladies.
I'm sorry your dad didn't stick around.
I,
uh,
it was just dreadful.
Yeah,
whatever.
You'll see it someday.
If I ever decide to run for president,
you know,
and I'm fine if I don't fall in line,
the fucking NSA.
Well,
Hey,
this is what he jerks off to.
Um,
anyway,
you know,
some,
uh,
you know,
it's pissing me off as the amount of people who aren't supporting that Snowden
guy.
I think there's a lot of people,
I'm going to go on a limb here and I'm going to say there's a lot of people that
don't like it and spied on,
you know,
think it's completely unnecessary and think that and view that Snowden guy as a
whistle blower,
not as some sort of trader,
but you,
you,
you just know that you can't say that.
You can't say that shit on TV.
And uh,
that's not a nine 11 thing.
That's a fucking post Vietnam thing.
I was thinking about that the other day where they had,
everybody was singing songs saying,
you know,
protesting against the war.
I'm not saying whether it was right or not,
but you could do that back then and you didn't get that Dixie chick treatment.
You know,
that shit where they will like,
well,
they had the right to sing it and we have the right to disapprove of it.
It's like,
yeah,
you do say add an appreciate that,
fuck them.
But when you take it to the level,
you'd try to systematically destroy their ability to make her earn a living,
then,
uh,
you know,
that's not tit for tat.
That's like,
Hey,
I threw a rock at you and you'd drop the fucking bomb on me.
Hey Dell,
why don't you get to some topical material from this fucking decade?
All right,
sorry.
Um,
the hell was I talking?
I don't even what I was talking about,
I got so self conscious that I was somehow talking about the Dixie chicks.
Oh yeah,
yeah.
Back in the day,
you could,
you could fucking,
you know,
you could
say,
uh,
you know,
you could say things and it wasn't all tied into,
supporting troops and love and babies and,
uh,
being pro ice cream and against the terrorist.
It's like,
it's fucking a,
it's really childish,
really childish era that we're living in and it's gradually seeping into what it
is that I do for a living where there's these complete,
uh,
nincompoops.
Can I use that word that are deciding to go to comedy shows and take jokes
seriously?
I mean,
how old are you?
I,
I can't,
I can't.
Um,
what are you going to do next?
Go to the circus and watch the clown hit another cloud with a rubber hammer and
God's promoting violence.
He could get a concussion.
No more rubber hammers at the SARC is,
and what the fuck is wrong when you grow up?
You know what I mean?
I love her.
They think that like,
comedians have this,
this fucking level of power that they're going to do a joke.
Okay.
And that people in the crowd are so fucking stupid that that's going to form
their worldview.
You know,
like if I did a joke that was like pro chopping somebody fucking handoff,
I are you really telling me that there's people out there that are so fucking
stupid
that they're going to walk into a comedy show before they walked in.
They had no desire to do it and felt that doing that the to another human being
was a terrible thing to do.
But then once I make a joke about it,
all of a sudden there's going to be a bunch of people walking around chopping
people's hands off because I joked about it.
It's,
it's,
it's unbelievably fucking childish and it's condescending and,
uh,
I dunno,
I just keep seeing more and more of that type of shit,
by the way,
for people to get up in arms about some of those jokes.
Uh,
that one,
because I don't want to feed the fire here,
but you know,
that one topic that you're talking about also could happen to a man,
you know?
So
I don't know why you feel like it's,
it's just yours.
I was actually joking about that on stage.
I'll burn the bit,
won't gives a fuck.
You know what it is,
at least when it happens to them,
people give a shit.
If it happens to a guy,
they,
people literally think it's funny.
They laugh.
You know,
I remember when that do get his dick cut off by his wife.
He was cheating on his wife and she cut his dick off and she threw it in the
garbage disposal and turned it on.
And there was one of those shows that was ripping off the view is the one that
has the Asian lady.
I don't even know if it's still on,
but they were talking about it and they were snickering.
You know what I mean?
It was fucking funny to them.
It's horrific.
Gives it was they found humor in it.
So I,
I dunno,
I ain't know the fuck I'm talking about anymore.
I let,
let's,
let's do a little little advertising here.
Uh,
I'm sorry about the clicking of the,
uh,
whatever this fucking buttons called.
I'm sure Bobby knows what it's called that,
but he's getting,
I bet he has some,
the latest one dad.
I got the lays fucking Steve Job fucking space by thing get um,
I said it.
Bobby Kelly smarter than me.
We're actually doing a two man comedy show off off Broadway called Bobby Kelly
smarter than me.
It's kind of like a George Burns,
a sunshine boys type of thing.
By the way,
Robert Kelly,
if you guys were up in Canada,
I heard he murdered it up at the Montreal comedy festival.
All right,
but enough about that content.
Let's talk about the dollar shave club.
Everybody,
they're all asleep shave club.
Um,
it's a cool brand.
I hate how they do.
This has made me so much happier about shaving.
No,
it hasn't.
Okay.
It's fucking convenient.
I totally recommend it.
Stop putting fucking words in my mouth.
Anyways,
dollar shave club,
everybody has made my life way more convenient.
Um,
it's a cool brand and they send you quality razors right to your door every
month.
You don't even have to think about it.
You don't even have to wait in line.
You don't have to get someone to unlock that cage for you,
like they've taken out a bar of gold.
You don't have to pay way too much money for a bunch of features that don't even
fit on your old handle.
Alright?
Shaving has become such a mess.
Okay?
It's a complete rip off.
All right,
the snake oil salesman,
it's a little plastic piece of crap with,
with like,
it's not even aluminum.
I don't even know what it is in there,
okay?
It's a piece of crap and they've been charging you an arm and a leg for it.
Well,
who's coming to the Rescue Dollar Shave Club?
All right.
I want you to go out and try it.
I dare you to try this product and tell me you're not satisfied with it.
Do you think about that?
See that advertisers,
I don't need you to write words for me.
Um,
well,
this part I do support the show.
Go to dollar shave club,
forward slash burr or click [inaudible].
Click or click on the dollar Shave Club banner on the podcast page at
[inaudible] dot com.
All right?
Then you don't have to deal with it.
You don't have to deal with it anymore.
No more standing in line for him.
Of those old people,
you know,
going some understaff,
cvs,
trying to find somebody who actually can walk away from the cash registers.
Stress Slash like ice cream.
You know,
it's funny.
Old people buy ice cream and like pharmacies,
you know,
they don't care.
They don't need it to be hugging.
Does.
Is there dairy in there?
Is it cold?
We'll put it on a cone.
You fucking cunt.
All right.
Ah,
sorry.
Most of this rage has to do with the fact that I feel like an idiot that I
didn't bring the power strip thing or whatever.
It's not a power strip.
The plugin thingy that goes into the back of the do Hickey.
Um,
all right,
so now you don't have to buy,
um,
you don't,
you don't have to worry about buying a shea.
Uh,
what do you call blades for your shaver?
Shaving blades.
Is that what they're called?
I don't know.
I wouldn't it be nice if you didn't have to deal with that.
You also didn't have to go to the post office.
Well,
why don't you go to stamps.com you know,
quit staring at the lamp.
Grabbed the reins or your life.
All right?
Postage meter companies used to have a monopoly on printing postage.
They could charge you an arm and a leg to print postage from your own office.
But those days over,
oh,
not like Michael Corleone said Corleone.
Is that what he's planner.
Now you can use stamps.com instead with stamps.com get all the benefits of a
postage meter,
but at a fraction of the cost,
all you need is your computer,
your printer and stamps.com to get,
uh,
to get official US postage for any letter or package,
any class of mail.
It's so damn convenient.
Plus you'll never have to step foot inside of a crowded post office again.
All right?
This is your whole Saturday morning,
right?
Paying your bills,
driving down to the post office,
stand in line,
and then you go over to cvs to buy his shaving blades.
You don't need to do this anymore.
All right?
Get with the times,
man.
Everything you would do at the post office you can do right from your desk.
It's so convenient.
All right.
I use stamps.com they send out all my march for when I whore myself out after my
shows.
And you guys know how dumb I am.
So if I can do it,
anybody can do it right now.
Use My last name [inaudible] for this special offer,
no risk trial plus a $110 bonus offer that includes a digital scale and up to
$55 free postage.
What more do you need?
Don't wait.
Go to stamps.com before you do anything else,
click on the microphone at the top of the homepage and type in burpee.
You are that stamps.com enter burr.
All right,
back to the podcast and I apologize for the click.
Um,
all right,
where the hell am I here?
Um,
oh,
this is what I did before I came to New Orleans.
I um,
I did the first leg of the uh,
Billy red state tour with a limited edition tee shirts.
And these aren't limited edition.
They're only going to be sold on the red state tour unless I don't sell all of
them,
at which point they'll be available to everybody.
You see that?
That's called honesty in advertising.
Um,
but anyways,
I got,
I went to Boise,
Idaho and uh,
then I drove up
to Bozeman,
Montana.
It was like a s unbelievably great like seven,
eight hour drive could have done in six.
But you know,
we were stopping along the way.
Me and Lucas Seely comedian,
I met back in the day when I used to do this guy's room.
My giggles comedy club that no longer exists,
exists,
sadly,
was such a great club.
And uh,
I loved that club owner,
man.
He was such a character.
You know,
the first weekend I worked with this guy,
he came out
and gave me a shoe box full of like fives,
tens ones like was my money for the week.
It was thinking that I was just going to have that under my arm and go walk
through fucking airport security and not look like a fucking,
like I was dealing crack,
you know,
I still remember it was one of those,
one of those boxes that you put that baseball's in,
and he had all,
he had the piece of paper to say how many comps there were yet all the
information.
He had it in a shoe box and it looked like it looked like he was trying to raise
money for kidney dialysis.
You know,
or maybe he was playing the Banjo on the sidewalk and everybody just threw money
in there every which way.
And,
uh,
I don't know.
Back then,
I hadn't read about banks today.
I probably would have taken it.
I would've counted it out.
I would have taken it.
But then at the end of the day,
it's just a piece of fucking paper.
Um,
so anyways,
I,
but,
uh,
it was such a great room
and I had so many fun,
uh,
shows when I was there.
And I,
uh,
along the way,
I met a bunch of great comps.
They're great scene there in Seattle.
I hope they still do.
Um,
I haven't been there in a minute,
but,
uh,
I met this
do Luke Lucas Sealy.
So we did a Boise,
Idaho the first night,
which was right on the campus of a Boise State University.
For some reason I didn't realize that that's where I was performing and uh,
it was phenomenal.
I took video,
um,
I could get into the stadium,
but I was in the corner of the end zone.
I saw a little bit of that iconic blue turf.
And I know a lot of people from the bigger schools will give me shit for calling
that iconic.
Well fuck you all right.
And yet god Damn fucking your,
your school songs that all sound the same.
You know,
bad,
the same guy,
right.
All of those fucking songs.
Um,
and that was the only three that,
you know,
right.
The Lsu,
when I recognize it,
when I hear it,
um,
you know,
it's funny being down here in New Orleans,
I keep forgetting I'm here.
So every time I see an Lsu shirt,
I like light up.
Hey,
Lsu,
Lsu.
I keep stopping myself from saying that.
That'd be like in Boston.
Red Sox,
right?
Red Sox.
Oh,
by the way,
I'm slowly,
I'm back into baseball.
I don't know what happened.
I just been on the road and I'd been watching games and I've been watching like
the,
uh,
I've been watching the half nots,
you know,
been watching the royals and watching the Indians who actually are the haves.
They just can't ha ha,
like,
hang onto their guys.
Um,
I've already given you that theory of why they should have an honor.
Honor every world series.
Fucking trophy.
You know,
Philly's the Yankees,
the Red Sox,
we all stole all of that.
Fucking guys didn't stay on,
but whatever,
you know what it is.
MMM.
We use them as a farm team.
It's bullshit.
I liked them.
I liked the Indians.
I liked the royals.
I like the pirates.
I liked the,
uh,
the devil rays or they lost some points by calling themselves to raise.
That's another childish fucking thing.
How old are you
devil rays that either it's going to make kids evil,
you know,
why don't you just call the pussies?
How about that?
Would that be,
you know,
the,
the Tampa Bay,
uh,
after you,
why don't you just call it debt?
No,
no,
no.
You,
you,
you eat the last slice,
the,
I don't know.
The Tampa Bay.
It was a pleasure meeting.
Use,
use.
I'm sorry.
Anyways,
let's get back to this shit.
So I,
um,
bull shows,
I don't know what was,
what got into me.
I,
I hadn't done standup in a minute.
I've been busy writing some other shit.
And um,
I did two of the law,
I think the two longest sets I've ever done.
I did like 90 minutes and I never do that,
you know,
cause I watched the comedian one time do two hours and I was sitting in the
crowd and write it in an hour.
I started looking at my watch and by like an hour 25,
my ass was falling asleep.
So I apologize to people in Boise,
in Bozeman.
I was just having a great fucking time.
And I was really excited about coming up there and,
uh,
it did not disappoint that drive from Boise to Bozeman,
Montana.
You owe it to yourself to do that and go through,
I know in what killed me is I didn't have the time.
I didn't have the time to go see the evil Knievel thing and I didn't have the
time to go into Yellowstone.
But you know,
I kind of took this highway that went right along Yellowstone and it was
absolutely fucking beautiful.
I saw wild horses,
you know,
granted they were on a reserve.
I took a picture and you could see the fence,
but they had a completely different fucking attitude that knows horses that,
you know,
you go down and ride across the fucking street on,
they hadn't been broken.
They still had the light in their eyes.
You know,
those other ones.
I like the ones,
you know,
in the fucking cubicles there in the Matrix,
somebody on their fucking back,
you know,
the Mustang stuff,
those are the guys.
Those are the guys.
Uh,
they're off the grid.
So anyways,
I saw them and then there was,
there was some place we could look at bears.
I love bears,
but I'm,
you know,
I'm also not a moron.
So two things.
One,
I don't want to see one that's wild and I don't want to see one in a fucking
cage.
I'll just watch him on TV.
And they had this bad,
the place where you could actually look at them and it was the worst fucking
name.
What?
What would you do if you had a bear sanctuary?
Just just for me.
What would you call it?
I'll give you five seconds to come up with the name and I guarantee you it's
better than what the fuck they called it.
Bear world.
You know
Jesus fucking Christ.
Yeah.
Is anybody creative in your fucking circle of business partners?
Partners.
We'll call it bear world.
You know there's bears and you know,
then the world.
So bear world.
I own them over a business.
I sell yard down the street.
Yarn world,
yarn.
Galaxy was was a choice.
I was going to make it fucking more,
I couldn't even stop there.
Bear world,
you know,
I should go in there and they should be,
should
be somebody in a fucking bear suit,
you know,
except it's not a joke.
He's actually trying to fucking pull it off.
Like he really is a bear,
you know,
if you're dumb enough to stop off at a place called bear world.
But I did have a good time in other places.
I went to this uh,
stopped off at this diner,
was actually a driving diner,
like fucking happy day ship,
but they weren't on roller skates and a,
he could pull right up,
but I still want,
I went in,
I wanted to see the,
the,
the place,
you know,
um,
see the pictures on the walls and all that type of stuff and I got a double
cheeseburger there with tater tots and a root beer and I have to tell you,
set the man,
it was fucking delicious.
You know,
it was even better.
It was a high quality piece of greasy meat because I didn't feel sick
afterwards.
I felt a little like,
why the fuck did I do that?
You know,
as you're Gunna,
when you do something like that.
But,
uh,
I feel like they had a better quality burger than you usually find in some,
you know,
a place like that.
I'm going to give them a shout out here.
What the fuck was it called?
It was called frost top driving in Idaho.
Uh,
it's been open since 1965 and I don't know if you ever wanted to just drive up
and not have to get out of your car and consume 4,000 of the most delicious
fucking calories you ever had in your life.
I highly recommend that.
It was tremendous.
And,
uh,
I'm a big fan of root beer.
I love it,
but I don't fuck with soda because,
uh,
you know,
I know what it does to you,
but that's the,
you know,
every once in a while when I hit the crack pipe,
that's what I get.
I get one of those fuckers,
either get one of those or if I can get one of the,
uh,
out in la they have,
they have the,
the,
the orange crush that actually has real sugar in it.
And it tastes like the shit when it,
when it first came out in the late seventies,
orange crush,
like put,
make it like put you in a better mood.
That's how good it fucking tasted.
Ah,
Jeez.
It sounds with a fucking days,
you know,
no stress,
no bullshit.
I had a fucking paper route.
Right.
I've had a job since I was in the third grade.
I was just thinking that the other day I had that paper route from third grade
to ninth grade to the point it was getting weird,
you know,
like my voice was changing and I'm like,
I don't,
uh,
help me,
to 60 for the week.
Uh,
what was it for the week?
$7 seven 25?
No,
no,
no.
It was like to 60 for the week and then if it was three weeks,
I remember it'd be like $7 and something cents.
And I would be nervous that the dad was going to answer and be fucking pissed.
Um,
I still remember time this time,
this personal me 1125 or something.
I finally got them when they were home.
They would just never fucking home.
And I finally got him and the guy actually laughed.
I still remember it.
He had this woodstove and he had the fucking thing cranking and it was freezing
out.
I was collecting,
I always hated collecting.
I,
like I said,
I've always been such a fucking loner.
It's probably why I do this podcast by myself.
I just like the delivering of the fucking papers.
I loved it riding my bike,
talking to myself,
you know,
I used to ride around on my bike and I would,
I would be doing fucking Carlin and prior bits that I had memorized,
pretending I was doing it in front of the class and I was still too fucking
stupid to realize that that meant that I wanted to be a comedian.
I was a moron.
Anyways,
I still remember that 1125 my bill for the week was like,
I dunno,
like 18 bucks maybe.
And I got 1125 off of this house and I had like 30 something customers,
so I was fucking roll in it.
You know,
I didn't have a mortgage.
You don't have a mortgage and you don't have rent and you don't have a woman in
your life and you got like 22 bucks,
right?
You're not gonna fucking cut.
Yeah,
you're,
you're a millionaire.
So I went up to the local store.
What did I do?
I invest my money.
Did I save it up now?
I went down there and I bought a bunch of football cards in a fucking giant
orange crush
and I sat right out of the store,
opened all of them,
stick in a fucking debt,
awful piece of gum that always tastes like shit,
but you just,
you had to put it in there.
It was more sugar.
Just shoved that thing in my fucking mouth.
It was like covered with like I,
it's like,
it's like someone was plastering a wall,
you know that shit when it comes down and it gets you your eyebrows and shit.
That's what was like on the gum.
I just sat there.
That's all I did.
And it was like one of the great fucking days of my life.
So every once in a while,
if I find an orange crush and it actually has the real sugar,
you know,
you know that sensory sense memories,
shit,
a fucking drink,
that goddamn
thing.
And I'm back out in front of that store.
Nobody's fucking with me to just me and my little bicycle.
Oh,
little Billy red freckle face.
Anyways,
the fuck am I talking about?
Oh,
you know what I did?
I came up with a good nickname for Lucas Sealy.
Everybody,
Lucas Siegel,
you know,
you're driving a car with somebody for fucking eight hours.
You just start talking about everything.
And uh,
he was talking about playing high school football and everything.
And I don't know why,
I just started thinking Chris Berman,
what Chris Berman would call them and I came up with is Chris Berman nickname of
uh,
what was it,
Lucas?
Now you see Lee,
now you don't,
and I was doing,
I know it's Corny,
but it was great in the car ride because I was doing the whole thing with Chris
Berman going now you see Lee and then I was doing Tom Jackson yelling,
now you don't,
and then I would do that.
Like he just made a fucking move and we will,
if we were having the time of our fucking lives,
I swear to God,
I wish you all,
you guys could just do something on the road once you got to fucking do it.
You know,
why don't you just accidentally like do something to the building that you work
in,
you know,
not in crazy.
Just fucking make big one of the shit pipes the pipe where the shit goes out.
Just fuck that thing up at some Osha Shit.
There's no way you'd have to come in.
And what could you do on a day though?
I Dunno,
I drove from Boise to Bozeman.
Hey,
you know what?
It's your fucking life.
I don't have time to figure it out.
You guys figure it out.
Um,
the hell am I talking about here?
So anyways,
trying to look here.
Oh,
so I'm in New Orleans and I'm going to try and be a good boy when I'm down here.
I'm going to try and not drink,
staying away from Bourbon Street and all those fucking animals down there.
The tits out,
walking around with their sunburned fucking area was,
I don't want to look at that shit.
I'm too old for it.
I can't do it anymore,
you know?
Um,
I'll wait.
I didn't finish telling the story,
so I went all the way up.
I know.
I'm all over the map.
Fuck you.
All right.
Um,
once again,
sorry for the clicks here,
I have to see where I'm at.
31.
How can you hear those people in the hall?
Oh,
you know,
I was staying when I was in a
Boise.
I was tired as shit and I was staying in this,
uh,
when I stayed,
I stayed in the western or the best western.
I know the fuck it was.
And a,
it was one of those things that looks like a hotel,
but it's not a hotel,
but,
but it's not a motel.
It's kind of a little bit of both.
It's like you're inside,
but I dunno,
it's just kind of flimsy doors and like the other side went out,
you know,
one side goes to the hall,
the other side is a glass door that they had these flimsy curtains and you open
it up in the fucking pools there.
So I'm tired and I want to do is just take a nap before the fucking show and
there's a bunch of kids in the pool,
you know,
playing games and screaming and yelling and shit and you know,
which I can tolerate.
MMM.
What they started running up and down the halls.
You know how you're excited as a kid,
hotel pool and all that shit.
You run every way you fucking go.
I swear to God,
by the time,
like the fucking ninth kid ran down the hall,
I was having these fantasies of quickly opened the door and just close lining
one of these kids.
And uh,
yeah.
So one of the reasons why it's probably should never be a father because I
really violent thoughts like that.
Um,
you know,
I had one at the airport and I'll sit there and flew Alaska Airlines up to Boise
and uh,
they didn't offer that skycap service,
you know,
so I had to go into the,
the airport with all the animals.
Okay.
Life is all about making enough money so you could buy your way out of the,
out of the pig pen.
Do you know when you go to the airport,
the pig pen is right in on the other side of that fucking glass.
If you have a,
if you have a bag that you're checking,
but even then,
even if you,
even if you just have a carry on,
you're going to have to deal with how fucking stupid people are.
You just going to have to do,
you can be standing behind somebody and you just have to deal with how fucking
stupid they are.
So I would rather,
you know,
just fucking pay.
Just what stands in the fucking line outside.
Have this guy.
Hey,
how are you Mr [inaudible]?
How's it going?
I'm good.
It's going great.
Tip of the hat is fucking a bunch of,
you know,
here's some money.
Good for you.
Yeah,
no thank you.
He is a great fucking tip for keeping me out of the pig pen.
God bless you.
That's how I look at it,
right?
So I show up Alaska,
they don't have,
you know,
they don't offer that.
What's right there is a fucking red flight.
It's like do okay.
You can't afford to pay those guys.
You know you're going to have enough gas in the plane.
You're going to have it on half a tank the whole way up,
trying to make it up you fucking dicks.
So anyway,
so I walk in there and it's just a complete,
I'm actually writing a blog about it.
It's really dark and evil and I'm going to put it up on all things comedy.
Um,
I'm going to finish it in the next couple of days or so.
But long story fucking short is it's a complete clusterfuck when you go in there
and they have one employee,
they have two lines,
they one employee for every,
for two lines,
you know,
one employee work in like two lines and everybody's huffing and puffing looking
at their watches,
wondering why it's taking so fucking long.
And then when they get up there and it's their fucking turn,
they're not ready to go.
They're like Thurman Thomas,
they don't have the fucking helmet.
They were in the huddle without their fucking helmet.
And I swear to fucking God,
I sweat.
And I then what I do is I just start muttering every fucking curse word,
every fucking curse word I can put them.
Someone is always looking at me like,
like I'm like,
I'm the fucking guy who has the problem.
These fucking idiots.
They'll stand,
they'll stand like in a security line,
shaking their heads about how fucking long it's taking.
And then when get up there,
when it's their moment,
they're not ready to go.
Let me help you guys out here.
Not all of you,
but just for the fucking morons.
Okay?
And you should really take that as an insult.
Someone is dumb as me calls you a fucking moron when you standing in line,
okay?
You have all this fucking time to take off all the shit that you're going to
have to take off.
If you've got a jacket,
just shove it in the pockets.
Zip 'em up.
You got your watch and there you got your loose change.
You've got all your fucking metals in there,
okay?
You can undo your belt that's ready to go.
You know,
have you shoes ready to slip off mentally?
Think,
how many bins do I need?
Okay?
Fucking have a game plan.
You get up there,
you grabbed the binge and eat your fucking,
put them flush up with the person in front of you.
You put all your shit in them and when the person moves up in front of you,
you fucking move your shit too.
All right?
And that would cut down so much eye rolling in your fucking life.
Standing in those lines.
You know,
and this is just a waste.
It's a waste of time.
It's a waste of fucking time because people aren't going to get it.
They're not going to get,
they stand in line and he's fucking Tsa guys go over and over and over.
If you have any liquids,
if you have a laptop,
you have shows they have,
you have this dad does that Bob.
They'll bug and they say at 900 times and it drives me fucking nuts.
I used to hate them for saying it 50 times going,
why the fuck do you keep saying that?
And then I just watched people in front of me if it okay to have toothpaste and
a bed go up.
Why?
I took off one shoe.
Is that okay?
Like that shit.
I actually have empathy for them.
No.
Um,
this is another thing too.
When you go really small mom and pop airports,
like the one I flew out this morning in Bozeman,
Montana.
Um,
it was so small.
My fucking map app,
whatever the fuck you call it,
the Steve jobs map app,
it couldn't even find it.
It took me to somebody's house.
Oh,
you want to hear a cursing when the sun's coming up over those beautiful
mountains.
You know,
people broke thought they had a bear in the front yard.
That's how fucking upset I was.
Um,
anyways,
let's,
let's just get back to some happy shit.
So I go are we drive up to Bozeman,
Montana and it's fucking absolutely gorgeous
and uh,
actually promised him that I wouldn't tell him how nice it was so people
wouldn't go up there.
So I broke my promise.
They apologize to the people up there,
but it was fucking beautiful.
I'm so,
so I have to say it was fucking gorgeous.
And I ended up doing an hour and 40 minutes,
so if you're asked,
fell asleep,
I apologize.
I won't be doing that.
Uh,
I usually try to keep it to about an hour,
an hour and 10 minutes.
I broke the cardinal rule of leaving them wanting more,
but I,
there was something about the crowds,
like I felt like,
uh,
you know,
they was psyched that I,
I made the trek up there.
So I did an extra long shower
when I was psyched to be up there.
And I played two really,
really cool theaters and I'm definitely going to come back.
It didn't sell out either one,
which of course I love because that motivates me now.
Right now I've got to get this area that's like what the south used to be for
me.
I couldn't fucking,
you know,
I couldn't sell any tickets down.
I just kept going and going and going and going.
So I'm hoping the word of mouth,
we'll,
uh,
we'll spread out that way.
The very least they'll look at the red state tour and be like,
you know,
the tee shirt,
wonder who the fuck that is.
And hopefully I can come back and do it again.
But,
um,
because right now I'm supposed to be in deadwood,
South Dakota,
and I was,
I would have had the experience of driving all the way across Montana and South
Dakota,
which is something I really want to do.
And,
uh,
Oh,
last week,
speaking of motorcycles,
evidently that's the fucking place to ride a motorcycle.
I've never seen so many motorcycles in my life and pickup trucks and trailers.
Um,
I was saying the Lucas,
like basically that if,
uh,
I think up there,
if you,
if you don't have a four door pickup truck with a trailer and some sort of
fucking dirt bike or four wheeler on the back,
that you,
you know,
I think you get gay bashed up there,
right?
Isn't it?
Anyways.
Um,
all right,
let's,
let's do a couple more ads.
Get into your letters for this week.
Um,
where the hell is it?
Sorry about the clicking.
Okay.
Legal Zoom,
everybody.
Most Americans don't have a will,
but why?
That's really stupid to not have a will.
Um,
because you know people,
you're going to have loved ones fighting over it and the government comes in and
takes your stuff.
Bill,
why don't you just read the copy?
You don't have a law degree.
You know what?
You're right.
I'll go with you on this one.
You don't want the government.
You don't want government rules.
Jesus dictating what happens to your property and minor children of Jesus.
You've got to put your kids in there too.
I leave my seat.
My daughter to my sister.
So why procrastinate?
Most people say too expensive or too time consuming.
Uh,
my answer to that people is legal zoom.com too expensive.
You're going to love legal zooms,
reasonable prices,
too.
Time consuming.
You say most people finish the online process and just 20 minutes and we're not
take,
we're not talking some fill in the blank form here.
That's not what we're talking about.
Your will is state specific and personalized based on your information.
Best of all,
legal zoom has 12 years of experience helping people with important legal
matters.
It's national.
Make it make a will month.
Sorry,
it's national.
Make a will month everybody energy.
So don't wait any longer.
Go to legalzoom.com today and get 15% off your last will.
Uh,
but this offer ends soon.
your last will.
Yeah,
you only get to die once.
Whatever.
Anyways,
I'll get a living trust and you'll receive a pour over will absolutely free to
get your special discount offer.
Be sure to enter burn in the referral box at checkout for wills,
powers of attorney trust and more.
Go to legal,
zoom.com legal zoom can provide self help service but at your specific uh,
direction or connect you with an attorney but they are not a law firm.
Um,
this is actually something that really isn't a joke.
I got to unfortunately had,
uh,
I've had so many friends die in and out of this uh,
business and obviously,
um,
you know,
they were too young to go so a lot of them didn't have wills,
some did,
some didn't.
And the ones that did it was one less thing to worry about.
So you know,
if you got people you care about,
you really should do it.
Okay,
that's the end of my little law left turn there.
Alright,
Hulu plus everybody,
I'm sure you've tried hulu.com but I want to tell you about Hulu Plus
Hulu plus lets you watch thousands of hit shows anytime,
anywhere streaming on your TV or goal or on the golf with your smart phone or
tablet.
Why stand in line or ride a train and just stare at your feet?
Why do that?
You could be watching your favorite shows on Hulu plus Google plus is a great
way to binge watch your favorite shows.
Um,
I missed,
what am I saying?
Didn't,
what are they doing here?
Why are you telling me that I'm going to catch up on this shit.
Stop Writing Shit for me to say here.
I like Hulu plus.
Okay.
I think you should get it.
I want to get it.
You don't really need to pepe makeup stuff about stuff I'm not watching
anyways.
Um,
that on Hulu plus if you ever decide to,
if I ever decide to watch all of Lost Hulu plus is the place for all that you
know,
I just realized I have to apologize.
The Google plus,
they're just using this as a jump off point.
I'm supposed to put in the shows that I'm watching on Hulu plus and like an
idiot.
I'm taking this literally,
this is why I didn't come up with Hulu plus cause I'm a moron.
But the people at Hulu plus they are not,
it's only seven 99 a month,
seven 99 for all the shows and movies you can watch.
What more do you want?
Do they got to show up and just give you a TV or a smart phone?
Catch up on current shows.
Binge on all your old favorite favorites in our catch.
A great movie.
You can do it all at Hulu plus right now.
You can try Hulu plus for a couple of weeks for free on me when you go to my
podcast page bill bird.com and click on the Hulu plus banner or go to Hulu
plus.com/bill burr.
Uh,
please make sure you use the Hulu plus.com/bill so you get an extended free
trial.
And so that they know that I sent you.
It helps us get to want to do now instead of stuttering.
I'll just slow down the sentence.
It helps us keep up the lights,
what it helps us keep the lights on and gives you a better deal.
One more time for the extended free trial.
Hulu plus.com/bill.
Cool.
All right.
Is that it for the uh,
the reeds for this week?
I think we got one more of this.
Space it out.
Okay.
Here we go.
Oh,
by the way,
I want to talk about something else here.
Uh,
people keep,
uh,
oh by the way,
that topic,
I actually,
I just write out topics.
I can make an a setlist just shit I want to talk about.
And I tried to write down airport etiquette and uh,
before you laugh at me,
write it down on your post it there and it gets one of those words I've used a
zillion times and I've read it and that a zillion times it's,
you can tell I don't read that much.
I had probably read at least 500 times.
Do you think it would stick in my fucking hard drive at that point I tried to
spell etiquette.
I knew I didn't know how to spell it,
so I thought,
all right,
I'll just give it a shot and I'll be in the vicinity and the computer would be
like,
oh,
are you trying to spell this?
MMM.
I spelled etiquette e,
And,
uh,
other than underlining it and read the computer had nothing,
had no
Noah [inaudible]
didn't even say like eight a cat or something,
you know,
etiquette e.
All right.
Uh,
oh two things.
I had a question.
I'm in New Orleans.
Does anybody know of a rehearsal space out here where I could play drums?
You know,
they have drums already set up and I can just rent something,
you know,
something reasonable,
let me know.
Cause uh,
there's a lot of downtime when you do these things.
So,
and I don't want to be getting in trouble,
you know,
becoming belief Poeboy fat face down here because all the delicious seafood that
they stick in a fry later and it tastes awesome.
This fucking city is great,
but it's going to give you a heart attack if you stay here for three weeks.
So I'm trying to,
you know,
did the supermarket I bought,
so Nana's and apples,
I'm trying to get a fridge in here.
I got to do something.
Oh by the way,
somebody,
uh,
you know,
somebody sent me something that was saying shaming fat people,
fat shame does not work.
Um,
but you know what,
I actually,
I actually had a couple people that said I've actually motivated them.
I had this guy today but that she really made my day,
this guy say,
listen to the podcast,
you know,
and he took the good ribbing that I was given fatties out there and he started
eating one giant salad a day and working out,
doing whatever the hell he was doing.
The guy went from like two 20 something or to 30 something.
Dan,
he's down to one 69,
one 69.
So a bravo to you.
That made me feel great to read that tweet.
And uh,
you know,
who knows,
this could turn into a great show.
You know,
I'll do my biggest loser except I won't be nice.
I'll just sit there and I'll come out like a comedian now.
Just have a microphone.
I just trash it every day.
I'll just sit there and make it fun.
Are you on?
That would be two weeks.
I'd start off maker.
I do it in a,
in a,
in a tough love way.
Okay.
Jesus Christ.
What channel would that be?
How high up on the fucking dial.
Would that be?
Okay.
Right there.
That no network's going to touch that.
Nobody under channel 700.
Yeah.
Fuck with that Nigga.
I'll just do it on my,
I'll do a web series.
I'll do it.
I'm,
I'm on my own website.
Oh.
Freckled face production.
Um,
all right,
here we go.
Letters for the week.
Serbian love.
Look at this.
See that you start learning capitals around the world.
You start getting a,
you start getting letters from people.
This is great.
I love when I get a letters from people from other countries.
I've never been to Serbia.
Everybody.
Do you know what the is?
I knew it two weeks ago,
but I haven't done it in two weeks.
It's new knowledge.
What the fuck is it?
It's not bright,
bright Bratislava.
Nah.
Is it?
I'm an asshole.
I'm sorry.
Yeah.
The Serbs eat the Bronx.
That's how I remembered it brought a Slava,
I think.
I Dunno.
Hey Billy Hill.
I liked that Benny Hill.
We be beginning.
Um,
this is girl who lives someplace around my place.
I like this guy.
He's being nice and vague.
This sounds scummy already go.
I like your sir.
Um,
I don't know where,
but I see her around every so often.
Oh,
you just don't know where she lives.
I thought you was saying,
Hey,
this is this chick.
She lives somewhere around my place.
I don't want to get into it,
but let's just say she suck my Dick in an establishment that had a roof where
you wouldn't get wet if it rained.
Um,
the problems are number one,
I'm 15.
It's sucks.
No,
it doesn't do it.
It's great to be 15.
Okay.
You know,
you got a lot of freedom.
Um,
and so is she.
Okay,
so what's the problem?
Jesus Christ,
what do you want to do with this girl?
He goes,
we just finished elementary school in Serbia and we used to go to separate
grades and number two,
I think I love her.
She's really smart,
beautiful and funny.
The usual and me looks wise.
On a scale of one to 10.
I'm slightly above five.
Jesus,
come on man.
All right.
First of all,
my first piece of advice is sit up straight when I'm reading this to you.
Come on man.
We going to build you up by the end of this,
uh,
five feet out tall and I like to waste my time listening to a 40 year old pasty
fellow who complains about his big head and overblown chelation.
My problem is we haven't ever had the chance to properly introduce ourselves to
one another.
I sometimes see you're on the tram and wave to her just to make sure she
acknowledges my existence.
That's good dude.
You're in the game.
You got your uniform on,
you got your foot on the top step of the dugout.
You're not in the batter's box yet.
You're not even on the on deck circle swinging the two beds,
but you're there.
All right.
I like this.
Okay.
You making positive moves here.
Okay,
so he goes,
I want to ask her.
I want to ask her on a date,
but I don't know her yet.
Can you tell me what to do?
Greens from Serbia come over some time so that we can kidnap you.
Hey,
was that the place where uh,
did that place used to be?
Uh,
the,
the country that Clinton bombed because he stuck that cigar in that girl's Twat.
Sorry about that.
You know,
whether that be fucking ridiculous.
I go over there and I take an ass kicking for Bill Clinton.
You know,
I just think the fact that my name is bill,
that that right there,
there would be enough for them then it was out.
So what is your prime,
you want to ask around on a date where you wave to her?
This is what I,
you know,
look,
you can't just wave to somebody on the tram and then just get in their grill and
ask 'em out.
You know,
this you got to like,
cause you kind of know her,
you know what I mean?
Look,
if you just meet a girl on a train,
if you meet a girl on the train,
this is what you'd do.
This is what I used to do.
I would wait for somebody to do something like some crazy person to get on and
they would do something fucked up.
I would hope that that would happen because I didn't have game that would just
walk up and start talking to somebody.
But in New York,
somebody always did something fucking weird.
And then,
well,
you know,
there's that moment where somebody doing something fucked up that strangers look
at each other like,
are you fucking kidding me?
And that's like an opportunity to kind of maybe say something funny.
You sit next to him.
He sat across from them.
I didn't have sitting across from you gang,
who's getting hill?
I didn't have a lot of game.
Why the fuck are you asking me?
Um,
all right,
what would I do here?
All right,
so you're doing that.
Why don't you,
uh,
why don't you properly introduce yourself,
start chatting with them,
you know,
and don't introduce yourself.
Tipping your hand.
Like you're going to ask her out.
Like,
Hello,
my name is Lourdes Serbia Jr uh,
you know,
getting down on one knee.
Just say what's up to a shoot the shit with her and make her fucking laugh.
You know,
you gotta,
you gotta get yourself in our world.
You know,
who knows.
She could be on the other side of that train.
Go.
Why is that con just waving to me?
You know,
why doesn't he come over here?
Doesn't he know that I'd like to,
uh,
go to the Serbian Cineplex if it still stands up.
I was just picturing a bombed out movie theater that's like sort of a drive in
but also has seats.
Uh,
I'm sorry.
I am the ugly American right now.
You know what?
Because you wrote me to me,
I'm going to try and learn a little bit more about your country.
Is that over there near a Bosnian Herzegovina
Slovenia,
Jubal Gang,
Jana,
whatever the fuck it is.
I don't know.
I'm not gonna lie to Ya.
I'm going to be honest or eastern Europe scares me for that exact reason.
There's,
there's uh,
I did,
you know what they should do rather than just showing you like they should in a,
in a geographical way,
show you where all the countries are and then also in everybody's country,
they should,
they should have kidnap countries,
cool countries,
cool.
But it's not worth going.
Uh,
and this place sucks or whatever.
You know what I mean?
They should group them up like that,
you know,
could get kidnapped here.
You could have a weed,
you know,
you can have your boogie board stolen and replaced with weed and now you're
going to get fucking put to death.
Was that in Bali?
Um,
I dunno.
So that's what I would do.
All right.
I think it's great that you're actually,
uh,
you know,
waving to this girl and everything.
This is a great thing about women.
They're all right with you if you're a five,
if you have a personality,
okay.
If you're a,
you know,
what's great thing about being a five is you weed out all this stuck up cons
cause they're not going to fuck with you because you're a five.
And then you know the materialistic and like cons
when they're in their teams,
how they're materialistic because nobody really has money at 15 they're
materialistic with looks.
And as they get older,
what it ends up being is the,
you know,
those cons end up going for the fives,
the bald fat guys,
but they're going after their money.
So this deal,
you're a five,
you probably not.
I bet you're like a strong seven if not an eight.
All right,
you just got,
I think it'd be too hard on yourself.
All right,
so
what am I trying to say here?
If you're an average looking guy,
you,
your chances of meeting a sweetheart,
how are are much higher.
If you're the good looking guy,
the quarterback on the team or the fucking playing soccer or whatever the fuck
you do over there,
you know,
it's like you're a celebrity.
You don't know which cheerlead is gonna blow your first and that just Yay.
You don't know what's going on,
you know,
but you,
you are actually,
you have the kind of looks where you can actually sit there and from a distance,
fall in love with somebody in pine for somebody and wave to them on the train
and then be like,
oh,
what did I say?
Something?
You know what?
Fuck this.
You think you're going to marry this girl?
This is the,
this is the one.
You walk up to this girl and you get,
you get all your fucking awkward shit out of the way.
Learn how to talk to a woman with this woman.
Okay?
And keep those,
those uh,
those skills sharp because one day,
you know,
when you do meet the love of your fucking life,
not saying this girl isn't,
but if you do,
why you won't be writing a dumb fuck half a world away.
All right,
hope that helped Gel.
last week I talked about tattoos,
people who have inspirational sentences written on their rib cage.
Um,
that's what I love.
And it's on the fucking rib cage where they can't even read it.
So it's like that's clearly for the rest of us.
You as you've learned this lesson and it's so important to you that you have to
turn yourself into a fucking posted.
All right.
Now I've got a lot of,
lot of emails about this.
Lot of people like defending their paragraphs,
you know,
some people saying,
look,
I had hope written on my arm and if I didn't,
if I didn't see that every day that I,
I,
that I would have forgot.
You know,
I might be a moron.
I just don't understand why you just can't write that down on a post it,
I have a post it right here,
right on.
No,
this is what I have.
Eat healthy practice drums,
no booze,
have fun giant salad every day if possible for dinner.
Okay.
Post it right on the mirror.
Wake up in the morning.
There it is and it just game plan.
I don't even have that written on my fucking rib cage.
Then there was other people though,
you know,
somebody who had like never forget and they were fighting over in Iraq and they
lost a bunch of their buddies over there.
I'm not talking about that shit.
Okay.
You know what I'm talking about?
I'm talking about dead stitch in time.
Saves the fucking book,
but the bill,
you know,
it's not always the,
the rook that queens the night,
sometimes it's the pon whatever the fuck.
You know,
that dumb shit.
So yeah,
I got a lot and I got a lot of emails from women with feet tattoos that are no
longer want to listen to the podcast.
Um,
don't take the jokes too seriously.
People saying this is the class they think why you can't take jokes.
Seriously.
You can't do it because people are selfish.
That person with the foot tattoo,
they laughed about all the fat fuck stuff.
Unless they're a fat fuck too.
Then they'd have a fat foot and in a hole they could have a whole mural put on
their chubby foot.
All right.
Hey,
this is,
this is a,
uh,
this is an email from a tattoo artist.
He said,
Bill,
just heard your podcast where you talk about assholes getting their favorite
poem,
Bible verse or inspirational quote tattooed on them.
I've been tattooing for 25 years and let me tell you,
this is the worst trend in tattooing yet.
We all hate doing this shit and managing.
He's talking about the tattoo artists at our shop.
We call the customers that want this.
They want this crap.
Skin poets,
the tattoos suck to do.
It's like a school assignment and they don't fit the shape of the body very
well.
We get a lot of those spiritual yuppy fucks coming in and wanting something they
saw on a tiger woods poster
or what?
Like just do it.
Um,
no fear.
What are some of those dumb ones they have?
I hate those fucking things,
you know,
24,
seven,
you know,
I hate those things.
Unless a little kids wearing them,
then they're fucking hilarious.
I saw a little kid,
he had a shirt on that said,
play me or trade me.
And I thought it was fucking hilarious.
Um,
but you know,
if you're an adult and you get to walk around with,
this is what I do on your tee shirt.
I don't know.
Um,
anyways,
he says he continues.
He says you really want to read the same paragraph over and over.
I think it all started with Megan Fox.
I guess she has shit written on her.
He said,
I miss doing butterflies down by the ass crack.
Uh,
love the show.
Played for the white sometimes and go
see.
We all like the go fuck yourself dude.
This guy literally did not use any spaces
or whatever.
I read it well enough.
Well there you go.
That's from a tattoo.
Artists Tattoo artists don't like doing it.
They call you skin poets.
So whatever.
There you go.
Skin poets.
All right.
And I'm not talking about,
look,
you know,
if your dad died and you got something on,
I'm not talking about that shit.
All right.
I'm talking about where you got to have some sort of,
you know,
something deep,
man,
that's like,
uh,
I dunno.
You know what I'm saying?
I'm too dumb to fucking even say what I already said.
All right,
Bill,
this is from New Zealand.
I believe this is great.
This,
this says you're the,
you're the only ginger I do.
Hey Bill.
I'm a 31 year old girl from New Zealand.
Hey,
say what's up to Phil Rudd for me,
William.
Um,
anyways,
I stumbled across you on youtube a while ago and I began listening to you in the
cab.
I like to drive along,
cracking up like a nutcase over the shit you say,
while other drivers look at me and wonder why I'm stoned.
Ah,
well this is why I do the podcast and also to hit my kids.
Uh,
she says I got my husband and kids hooked on you.
Youtube.
No need to pay me for the publicity.
Well,
I hope they're not listening.
Considering you just told you,
said you'd fuck me.
I'm,
I'm sure you're just joking.
Right.
There you go.
Just in case you get in fucking case,
your husband plays for the all blacks,
you know,
just give you a fucking soccer knee to the face.
Or is that rugby?
The rugby,
I dunno.
Um,
I also want to share that with also want to share with you the fact that you are
the only fancy pants.
I never heard that I have ever wanted to bang.
So feel special.
Sweet.
Do you realize how fucking condescending this is?
You know,
as you sit out there and that fucking island in the middle of goddamn nowhere on
the half of the planet that doesn't do shit on the of the other hemisphere was
the last time anybody from that hemisphere did anything.
Jesus.
How many people might pissing off right now?
This has nothing to do with that hemisphere.
It has to do with this.
Like I should feel fucking,
yeah,
why you acting like I put out a personal ad said no one ever fucked me before.
So feels special.
What the fuck is wrong with you?
I don't understand this new,
this.
It's like it's happened since I started doing this podcast where all these like
um,
this red,
I don't know if it was underground hatred of redheads or everybody watched that
South Park episode.
You're a bunch of hacks and you're fucking stealing off of their jokes.
But I've had a tremendous fucking life.
It's really,
and I,
I never,
you know,
I guess when I was younger,
when I had orange hair,
you know,
I felt like a fucking freak and I took the beat downs,
but once you were in adults and what?
Fuck sweetheart,
I don't need sympathy.
Pussy from half a fucking world the way.
Alright,
go fuck yourself.
I should feel privileged.
I don't know what the fuck you look like.
Do you know what kills me too about this,
this,
this fucking red hedge hatred shit.
The amount of fucking people that I,
that come up to me and I'm even good luck and go,
I'm better looking than they are.
I've been better.
I live a fat fuck man.
Tinted Brown haired dude coming up to me,
giving me shit about having fucking red hair.
It's like,
dude,
if you looked at yourself,
how many fucking mirrors do need to look at yourself?
You Tub a shit.
Look at your fucking nose.
You know,
fucking shark fin in the middle of your goddamn face.
I've got a great nose.
I have a nice job.
I have beautiful blue,
blue eyes.
I like myself.
That's all I need.
All right lady.
I don't even go to New Zealand to get some fucking on the side.
Married Pussy.
Jesus fucking Christ.
Anyways,
I just stopped reading that.
Yeah,
that's another thing too.
I've had,
everyone will say it saved me like,
yeah,
you're good looking for a redhead and I just want to say like,
you know what?
You're not that good looking for,
uh,
for a person.
Yeah.
I,
I'm,
I'm fine with how I fucking look.
So you guys,
you don't,
you don't need to have sympathy.
I don't mean like,
I'm fucking doing great.
All right.
Thank you.
Thank you for the,
uh,
trying to cheer me up with,
bestowing your,
your sacred pussy on me from the other hemisphere.
Um,
it's unreal.
She lives in a country.
Australia makes one of,
okay.
She should be happy if a fucking warthog climbs up are goddamn stairs.
They have worn hogs out there.
MMM.
Anyways.
All right,
let's,
let's put it here.
Aggressive Douche.
Hey Bill.
I'd been with my wife for six years and,
uh,
we've been married for one.
Congratulations.
He said when we first started dating a guy she knew turned up drunk on her
doorstep,
professing his love for her.
Oh,
Jesus Christ.
Jesus.
Wow.
He said,
I wasn't mad.
She's great.
And I couldn't blame them.
Well,
look,
if you have any empathy,
I would just be looking like Jesus Christ.
It's bad enough when they bring up an exit dinner.
Forget about the guy shows up at your house.
Z out there like John Cusack with a boom box over his head wearing a fucking
trench coat down.
Chew.
Forget about me.
What was that song?
I never saw that say anything.
I think I saw part of it.
I've always been bored with the love story.
Um,
there's something wrong with me anyways.
Uh,
this means we've,
well,
I screwed up here.
Oh,
she's great.
And I couldn't blame him.
Uh,
he goes on to say he was dating her friend at the time though,
and they are now engaged.
Oh.
So he went from your now wife to bang,
and you're now wife's friend and then realized that he had a better thing.
Yeah.
Jesus,
isn't it
fucking steamboat?
All this sunburn.
Tourists down there.
Hold the pull boys and fucking local,
the IPO IPA would have the fuck that is
okay.
Ah Right.
We get it.
You're on a Tom Sawyer boat gives a fuck.
All right.
Hey,
that's kind of Nice.
I shouldn't get mad at that.
That gives it a uh,
maybe you guys thought I was lying.
That was actually in my house and uh,
I misplaced the court.
All right.
There's no fucking steam boats.
You don't have your times at been here.
And I just found out that that's the Mississippi River.
I know that.
I knew that the Mississippi River emptied out into the Gulf here,
but for some reason I thought it was on the western side of the state.
I Dunno.
Anyways,
let's,
let's plow ahead.
Um,
so anyways,
he was dating her friend at the time though,
and now they are engaged.
This means we've been,
this means we've been for drinks with this couple of few times and they came to
our wedding.
Oh my God,
you didn't put the Kibosh on there.
Yeah,
that's hard though,
right?
Cause that's the x.
But he's with
her friend.
Oh God.
What did I see?
You got to elope.
That's the way to do it.
Anyways,
he goes,
I'm pretty laid back,
so I've been polite.
It was six years ago now,
over the last year.
He started liking her photos on Facebook,
pestering her when she's out with the girls.
Oh No,
dude.
I'm trying to message her on Facebook.
He must know.
She would tell me all this.
So he did
wait.
He must know.
She would tell me that all this.
So does he mistake my politeness for weakness?
Yeah,
absolutely he does.
He has a good woman already and I don't want them to break up.
Do I punched him in the face or smile as he ogles my wife.
Thanks.
And Go fuck yourself from some dude.
No,
dude,
you need to address this situation.
Yeah.
You gotta have you gotta have a talk with the guy.
MMM.
Oh,
but wait,
but they're friends.
This is what you do.
All right.
This is one of these confrontations you've got to have in a public place.
Uh,
tell me when to go out and have a beer or,
or are grab a sandwich or something like that and uh,
go out and just sit down,
ask him how he's doing and all that type of shit and just say,
listen,
uh,
you know,
me and my wife
are good friends with you guys.
And I'd like it to stay that way.
Would you like it to stay that way?
And at which point is he's gay.
He's already going to know what the fuck you getting at and just say,
listen,
I need you to
stop contacting my wife on Facebook.
All right?
You want to hang out as a couple?
You know,
go on and get some wine.
Eat some cheese,
tell some fucking stories.
That's fine.
But,
uh,
you know,
other than that,
you,
you need,
you need to back off.
Okay.
And I'm asking you this one time politely.
I'm not,
I didn't,
I'm not saying anything to anybody else.
I'm just telling you man to man.
Okay.
And,
uh,
you know what the,
what the fuck's he going to do?
He can't go home and tell his wife that,
you know,
that he's been,
stocking your wife.
He can't do that.
And um,
and make it even more uncomfortable and tell them that,
uh,
my wife knows that I'm here at Duke saying this to you too,
by the way.
So then it's,
that's,
it's just a close that,
all right.
You got to nip that in the buck because that is,
that is the beginning of,
of a creepy movie,
if you know what I mean.
You know,
I'm actually,
I actually got nervous halfway through that given you that advice.
That's why I was saying get into a,
uh,
public place.
You got to nip that fucking thing in the butt and I would actually have a
conversation with your wife too and say,
listen,
if,
uh,
this persists,
um,
we're not hanging out with them as a couple anymore.
Okay.
Because,
and if she gives you,
you know,
when he sees by Fred and blah,
blah,
and just say,
honey,
I love you.
I need a little empathy here.
What if one of my exes came to the door
five years ago?
Professing that she still had a flame for me and still loved me and all of that
crap.
All right.
And then was stalking me and liking my photos on Facebook.
How would that make you feel?
You know,
I'm not judging you,
but I wouldn't put you in that position.
Okay.
You liked that last sentence.
That last sentence is called game set.
Match.
Alright.
Uh,
walk.
Hey Bill.
Big Fan and all that.
Lapdog babble.
Now you need a new walk,
dude,
I've been,
I've seen a bunch.
I'll go fuck yourself.
I need a new walk.
You've watched all my specials on TV.
Well good for you.
Good for you.
Thank you for doing that.
Jesus fucking Christ.
All right.
Water toxicity.
A bill.
What toxicity is the medical term for when one's high.
Oh,
this is what I was talking about.
Uh,
what the fuck was it?
Um,
that person,
what is it?
The,
the,
they drank too much water.
Oh,
that's why someone was asking me.
Okay,
you know how much water you can drink or something like that.
You know what's fucking hilarious?
Cause the guy,
oh I know the guy said he drank a gallon and a half of water every day.
And I was like,
dude,
be careful man.
You drink too much water.
You could fucking die.
And the amount of fucking people that wrote to me telling me how much water you
can drink if 50 people wrote me,
they all had 50 different amounts.
Um,
so this person,
I don't know if this is an actual doctor or whatever,
said uh hey bill a water toxicity is the medical term for one's hydration.
When one's hydration reaches dangerous and sometimes fatal levels,
the actual mechanism at play is the ratio of water and electrolytes.
Salt in one's body.
Okay,
okay,
you've already lost me.
What are electrolytes is at that shit?
And Gatorade,
uh,
the total amount of water one can drink does not matter.
So long as the amount of electrolytes are in balance,
exercise and sweating depletes electrolytes.
So it is important to eat or mix in some Gatorade.
Rehydrating I was right.
Look at that.
Jesus.
If this was a multiple choice fucking test,
you know how dumb I am.
I actually read half of that and when I wasn't even paying attention to it and I
got to Gatorade and it snapped me back into it,
I just get like the second he goes scientific,
it's just Wah,
Wah,
Wah Wah Wah.
The total amount of water one can drink does not matter.
So long as the amount of electrolytes are in balance.
Ah,
exercise and sweating depletes electrolytes.
So it is important to eat or mix in some Gatorade when rehydrated I didn't know
that.
I used to eat a fucking piece of fruit so I wouldn't get sick when I sucked down
the water.
Uh,
the woman that died at the,
at the radio stunt drank and didn't eat then reached fatal levels.
Oh.
So basically they could do that if they had a bunch of Gatorade there.
Anyways,
love the podcasts.
My girlfriend and I saw your one night or in Tampa a few months ago and you were
fucking amazing.
Thank you.
Thank you very much.
Do you ever get a chance the Florida Georgia cocktail party game in Jacksonville
is the pinnacle of SCC football?
Is there I got to go to that.
I'm going to do that.
I'm gonna play the comedy zone one.
Uh,
one of these years.
I'll do like a one night or I'll do like Thursday,
Friday and then I'll be drunk on stage Saturday because I'm fucking having a
cocktail to,
but um,
I got to tell you
watched on the plane coming down here.
I watch that 30 for 30 again or maybe it was an east 60,
it seemed like it was an hour long.
I don't know.
On the Alabama Auburn rivalry.
And
that's one of my favorite pieces of television ever.
If you've never seen it,
if you not even into sports,
you just have to watch how insane
that fucking rivalry is.
And there's a guy,
what the hell is his name?
He has a radio show and I wanted to ask,
uh,
people who are living in Alabama who listened to the podcast here,
I know I'm going to say his name wrong.
Is Paul fine bond or something?
That radio show,
is there any way I can get that?
Can I listen to it online?
Um,
can you give me like a link or something?
I really want to listen to that this year as they're leading up,
I'm open Auburn's going to be good this year.
Um,
I know once cam left that they've,
they had a little bit of a drop off,
but uh,
I can't remember what they did last year,
but um,
I just want to listen to that shit talk and I,
I,
I was fucking laughing my ass off other than the maniac poisoned and poisoning
the trees,
which was just ridiculous.
But like listening to those people with those southern accent,
just yelling at each other and the amount of passion,
it was just,
it was,
it's just fucking phenomenal,
phenomenal fucking radio.
I have to,
I have to somehow figure out,
I have to go to that game.
Not only do I to go to that game,
but I have to figure out if I can't go,
I have to fucking listen to that.
Like I've actually already played it out in my head one of these years.
I'm going to go,
I'll go with like Verdesian law head or something,
maybe a couple other buddies.
And I was already picturing us getting there a couple of days early cause we'll
do standup probably at the star Doma something.
This is the game plan.
And in the mornings I just pictured us like hanging out like fucking eating
breakfast somewhere with the car radio on.
Just sitting there in the parking lot.
Laugh enough,
fucking asses off getting it.
There's no [inaudible] if you're not even in the college football,
if you just watch,
if you can somehow find that,
um,
that role tie war Eagle War Eagle Roll tide,
depending on who you talk to,
what should come first.
It's just,
it puts the Yankee red sub shit to shame.
It really does.
I actually think Ohio state,
Michigan puts Yankee Red sox shift to shame.
I mean,
Yankee red suck think died down now that the sox finally won it.
Um,
but uh,
it's just a,
it's just a whole other fucking level.
You've got to check it out,
highly recommend it.
So anyways,
one last,
uh,
advertising here for the week.
Um,
he voice,
uh,
your screening cloth.
Okay.
You're screening calls,
closing deals,
and making money all while lounging poolside in the summer sun.
Thanks to what he voice everybody.
Eve voice is a better way to connect with people that drive your business,
evolves for,
for business calls to your home,
mobile or any number you choose.
Wherever you are,
he voice.
We'll find you don't have time to take a call.
It's routed to voicemail and you can read it as you're at your own convenience
as a text message eve voice not only gives you an edge over your competitors,
it takes away the edge the big competitors
have over you right now with the voice.
You can create the appearance of a whole office building of departments.
When customers call you a sales department,
customer support,
tech support,
you name it.
It's going to sound like you've got a giant skyscraper with your name on the
side of it and it works with any phone.
Even yourself.
Hey,
it's summer.
Don't be stuck in your office all day.
You Jackass,
free yourself with a three 30 day trial of the voice so you can see what I'm
talking about.
Go to [inaudible] dot com and enter Promo Code bill for your 30 day free trial.
That's the voice.com Promo Code Bill,
or go to the podcast page on [inaudible] dot com and click [inaudible]
gone the voice banner.
There you go,
everybody.
That would be the advertising for this week,
right?
I'm done.
Nice.
Okay,
let's go onto the next one.
Uh,
dating an ugly girl.
Sorry about the click in here.
Everybody.
Jesus Christ.
Hour and 18.
Fucking chatty Cathy here.
All right.
Dolla dolla shade.
Oh,
I started reading the advertising.
I am so fucking stupid.
Clicking away dating an ugly girl.
There we go.
See,
they both started with a d so that,
that was enough to get me going.
Dating an ugly girl.
Hey Bill.
I just recently listened,
started listening to your podcasts at work and I've got to say,
great job,
man.
Thank you very much.
She say some truly funny and it's funny stuff.
Oh,
thank you.
Um,
I wanted to ask you for your advice on a troubling matter of mine.
I recently started dating a girl,
then I met on an internet dating site.
That's unreal.
I wish that shit was around when I was fucking single.
And that was a young man had a full head of hair,
right?
Jesus Christ.
I said,
going to the supermarket,
just picking out fruit,
you know,
AH,
Jesus Christ.
If you,
if you're letting your ego get in the way of fucking doing that,
your audience guide their mind,
still going out,
playing a fucking cover charge.
I guess there's the sport of that,
you know,
not having the gun cocked,
walking around with a shotgun broken over your arm.
Right?
Yeah.
Having your boy go flood,
flush him up,
flush him out of the fucking bushes
every once in a while.
That wouldn't be nice to fish in a stock pond.
Um,
anyways,
he said,
we,
we met on an internet dating site,
but we get along great.
Uh,
all,
we got along great through emails.
But when we met,
I was surprised to see how ugly her face was and how slightly off she smelled.
Ah,
you know,
I just did such a great commercial for why you should do Internet dating and now
you've convinced me that I,
I don't even know what I'm talking about.
All right,
so what,
what do you need advice at this point?
She has an ugly face and smells bad.
So what?
Oh,
Jason
[inaudible].
It's dating an ugly girl.
Okay,
well I'm intrigued now.
Well,
what do you look like,
sir?
Are you a little often?
Do you smell?
Did your smells combine and actually smell like something good?
Can that happen?
Can Two negatives make a positive in smells?
I know they're doing math.
Needless to say,
I was coming out of a dry spell also.
She has a great body,
so I put the moves on her.
I never actually hesitated.
He should have taken a fucking shower with her
as well.
That was the move right there.
You should have taken a fucking shower there and banged it.
Doggy style.
Jesus Christ.
Do I got to hold your hand over to the fucking water fountain?
Anyways,
he goes,
uh,
so I put the moves on her.
I never actually hesitated.
I just went on being myself around her and talking to her and now we're
together.
The sex is amazing.
I fucking knew it.
Okay.
I knew the sex would be amazing cause there's no other reason to stay with
somebody ugly and they smell,
they'd been a fuck the shit out of you or a,
you know,
they better find a new career because they have their fuck game is over.
Um,
playoffs now your season's over.
You're playing for a first round draft pick.
Okay.
All right.
The sex is amazing.
She has a pretty deep voice teases Christ.
This is like the money pit,
except instead of a house,
it's a woman.
All right?
She has a pretty deep voice for a lady.
So when we bang,
it's the only time she talks and acts like a woman.
Dude,
if you get to the end of this and this person has had a sex change operation,
I'm not going to be surprised.
Um,
Jesus Christ,
do I continue?
Yeah,
I got nothing better to do.
Fuck it.
And he goes,
uh,
blah,
blah blah.
And we get along great.
She's like the best friend I never had.
Yeah,
I'm sure she probably fucking lift more weights than your too.
Seriously.
We make each other laugh a lot and we're always learning and growing
intellectually with each other.
My dilemma is this.
I'm a pretty handsome guy and we go out.
When we go out together,
people always stare,
give us angry or confused looks,
oh come on man,
that might be in your head.
I bet.
I think a lot of that might be you being self conscious,
confused look like why is this great looking guy with this piece of dog meat?
I don't know if that's your ego or your date in the ugliest fucking thing ever.
You said she's got a nice body.
So you know what I mean?
Throws on a little makeup,
does some shit with her hair.
You know,
maybe comes in and her face a little
becomes 50% less.
Uh,
and this is just getting meaner by the second.
Um,
my dilemma is this,
okay,
blah,
blah blah.
I haven't introduced her to any of my friends and family yet because I'm afraid
of what they'll think of me.
And how they will judge us behind our backs.
Also,
I don't want ugly kids and that's pretty important.
Why are you with this person,
sir?
You're saying horrible things.
She has an ugly face,
she smells bad and you think she's gonna make ugly children.
What the what the fuck?
Okay.
You know what it is.
Your deck is still making the decisions in your life,
sir.
That's why you still with this person.
And secondly,
just because you're good looking and you get with the good looking person,
that doesn't mean you're going to have a good looking kid.
All right?
That's one of the fallacies out there.
I can name,
I can name a couple of celebrity couples drop dead gorgeous.
Had it and had an average looking kid.
Cause you know what it is.
It's not like your,
your beautiful and you're beautiful.
So together you make beauty.
No,
it's you're combining
your features.
You know what I mean?
There's a lot of average and you know,
I can tell you right now,
more times than not an average looking people have stunning kids.
They have jet order,
they have just as,
as a good a chance of making stunning kids.
This is like that shit I was talking to you about like a few weeks ago when I
was talking about like,
when people give like Michael Jordan's kid shit cause he's not as good as his
dad had basketball.
It's like,
well he's only half his debt.
He's Michael Jordan cut with Michael Jordan's wife.
Okay.
And if she has no leaping ability,
okay.
And can even catch a beach ball underhanded,
that's going to fuck with the son's ability to go to the rack.
You know.
So anyway,
that sir,
I,
I'll,
I'll read the rest of this book anyways.
Uh,
I don't want ugly kid and that's pretty important to me.
She,
she truly is an amazing person and in a perfect world,
I wouldn't hesitate to make her my wife,
but the fact is I'm too much of a bitch to completely accept her my life.
Well,
you know what?
You're man enough to admit that you're,
you're a bitch.
That's a good step.
Um,
which it is,
but I don't really want to hurt her feelings.
Her life is already pretty hard because of how she looks.
Do what it does she live in or a bridge.
What is the problem?
What should I do?
Am I too selfish and vein?
Any advice in this matter would be appreciated.
Well,
the problem is,
sir,
you've stayed with their long enough,
okay.
That she's starting to get into your heart.
You know,
she was in your balls first,
but then you know,
now she's up in,
in,
in your chest.
So,
uh,
yeah.
What would you do?
I mean,
well,
you have to make the choice.
Look,
you either accept her for who she is and you introduce her to people around you
or you get rid of her because you're going to hurt her.
You know,
that's it.
I don't know what the fuck else to tell you.
Nope.
I didn't come off like a dick there,
but I mean,
that's a,
it's just,
that's the deal.
You got to make the choice.
All right.
Okay.
They'll,
that's the podcast for this week,
everybody.
I apologize for being a moron and forgetting the plug and all that shit.
But,
um,
I did take a lot of video this week that I'm going to try to have uploaded onto
the podcast page and all that.
I'll try and make it up that way.
Um,
my,
my iPhone pictures and videos as I'm driving and I know it's not safe to be
doing that.
You don't need to point out all the people on the motorcycles.
I know that I was taking people's lives in danger.
You would hope the day during their lives.
So before you think of the most clever con on the fucking Internet,
um,
alright and send me all your hacky fucking shit about first world problems and
all that,
those other catch phrases.
Um,
anyways,
here we go.
Wrap ups.
All right guys,
now that the show's over,
don't forget to support our sponsors.
If you can get started with a free 30 day trial of the voice.
As I mentioned,
he voice gives you a toll free one 800 number or local number so you can call.
So you can take business calls from anywhere and always sound like you're at the
office.
Also,
we've voice has graced features like dial by name directory and even transcribe
your voicemail so you can read them at a conference.
All right,
go to [inaudible] dot com and enter the Promo code bill for your 30 Day free
trial,
uh,
or go to the podcast page,
built [inaudible] dot com click on invoice.
Uh,
also don't forget to sign up for Hulu plus it lets you bins on binge on
thousands of hit shows anytime anywhere and your TB PC,
smartphone,
or tablet.
Support this podcast and get an extended free trial of Hulu plus when you go to
the podcast page bill bird.com and click on the Hulu plus banner and then
Finally Dollar Shave club.com forward slash burr dollar shave club.com forward
slash bar.
All right,
you want to stop getting an EFT over by an razorblades.
Not only do you going to get them in for a fraction of the cost,
they can deliver my Tia damn house,
high quality razors sent to your door every month for a fraction of what you pay
at retail.
I love these guys and you will too.
All right,
I go to dollar shave club.com/bird.
Just go to the podcast page on [inaudible] dot com and click on the dollar shave
club banner.
And that is the show for this week.
Uh,
thank you so much to everybody who came out in Boise,
in Bozeman,
Montana,
for everybody else.
Deadwood,
Wichita,
Tulsa,
Colorado Springs,
El Paso,
all well those other dates.
I am making those up.
I'm doing them two,
three at a time to down like eight cds to go.
I'm bringing the t shirts and I'll do a nice long show for you.
Uh,
cause I fucked you over.
I had fuck you over.
I got an acting gig.
What am I supposed to do?
You know,
but uh,
I'm gonna make it up to you.
All right,
thanks for listening and uh,
go fuck yourself.
And now there's the long silence because I can't find the stop button and there
it is.